-Welcome back.
Our next guest is
an Emmy-nominated actress
you know from films such as
"Once Upon a Time in Hollywood"
and shows like "Fosse/Verdon"
and "The Leftovers."
She was nominated for both
a Golden Globe and a SAG Award
for her performance in "Maid,"
which is streaming now
on Netflix.
Let's take a look.
-The point is, honey, ah --
you know, I like being a gypsy.
I like being mobile, okay?
You know me. I'm scrappy.
-I don't know what to do.
I don't know what to do.
I can't afford to put you
in a motel.
I can't bring you
to the shelter.
I don't know what to do, Mom.
-I am not your problem,
Alexandra.
-Yes, you are.
-No, I am not.
I'm your mother.
-No, you're not.
-Yes, I am!
I am.
-Please welcome to the show
Margaret Qualley.
[ Applause ]
♪♪
Welcome to the show!
-Thank you so much.
-I'm so happy to have you here.
Now, that was your real mom.
-So, yeah, she says, "You're not
my mom," but she really is.
-In real life.
-Yeah.
-Andie MacDowell is your mom.
And this is -- you --
Obviously, a very
accomplished actress,
but you helped
get her this part.
That's a big deal.
-I know.
How crazy lucky am I, right?
[ Laughs ] Yeah.
-So did you suggest
to the producers,
"Hey, you know who'd be good
at my mom?
My mom."
-My mom. Yeah.
There's no real argument
for that, you know?
Like, what are you going to say?
"I don't believe that"?
-Yeah, she's not
a believable mom at all.
Do you remember
the first time as a kid
seeing your mom on screen?
Was it weird?
-Um, it certainly was. Yeah.
I, um...yeah.
I think the first time I really
remember it is actually,
it's a pretty vivid memory,
because my mom was going on
"Sesame Street,"
kind of on my behalf,
because it seemed like
a sweet thing to do.
-Sure.
-Yeah, so sweet.
But the way that I interpreted
it as a four-year-old --
well, she was playing --
she's from the South.
I am, too.
[ Laughing ]
'Cause she's my mom.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-Anyway, so she was playing
a Southern belle
stuck in a bell tower
on "Sesame Street,"
but she was away from home
while she was doing it,
and my four-year-old mind
was just like,
"My mom's stuck
in a bell tower."
You know?
Like, "This is awful."
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah.
Those muppets,
that can backfire on you.
Yeah.
-It was terrifying.
-It could be terrifying, yeah.
Very much so.
You are nominated
for a SAG Award.
Congratulations very much on
that.
-Thank you.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Thanks.
-And, you know, obviously a very
exciting time for your career.
I'm also aware that you had
a very tragic loss recently.
-I did, yeah.
-Someone who was incredibly
supportive of your career
and integral to it.
-Yeah. Yeah.
You know, to be honest,
I probably wouldn't be here
if it w--
I lost my manager
a couple of weeks ago.
He took his own life,
and it's just awful.
And I probably wouldn't be doing
something like this,
but I think that like, because
he's my manager, you know,
he'd be really pissed off
if I weren't doing this.
[ Laughing ]
So, but...
But yeah, his -- his family
actually started
a foundation on his behalf
with NAMI,
the National Alliance
for Mental Illness,
so if anybody wants to donate
to that, that's amazing.
But another thing to do is just
to tell the people that you love
that you love them, and just if
you are suffering, to seek help,
because there's people out there
that really want to help you.
And there you go.
-Well, thanks for being here.
-I've been great.
[ Laughs ]
-I can only imagine how proud
he was of you and your career.
And I also have heard that
he was also very supportive
on your behalf on social media.
-Oh, yeah.
Oh, yes, he was.
I mean, everybody loves Chris.
He's one of those, like,
real-life angels.
Anybody that ever was
in his orbit just made --
he made them feel
like they were family.
But with me, he's had my back
for the past 10 years,
but his Instagram presence
was particularly special
because he would --
you know, sometimes people --
people on the internet
aren't that nice sometimes.
-No, they're not, no.
-Shocking.
But when people would say
mean things
on a photo of me on Instagram,
he would personally go through
each comment
and then attack them
and like, go so far as to
provide his location
like, "I'm on the corner of
La Brea and some other street
in Hollywood, and I'm driving
this car and this is my outfit."
Like, "Come find me
and I'll tell you
what kind of a person
Margaret really is."
[ Laughter ]
So, yeah.
-Well, that is quite a presence.
-Really sweet.
-This show is a really
special show.
You have a -- there's an actor
who's not your actual
four-year-old.
You've got your real mom, but
not your real four-year-old.
-Yes, I haven't had
one of those.
-But a four-year-old actor
who's wonderful in it.
-Yes.
-But I would imagine,
especially for a show like this
that's so dramatic,
how do you keep
a four-year-old's attention
over the course of a day of
shooting, which are long days?
-It was hard.
I love her so much, Rylea.
So, so great.
But, and you know, to be honest,
the thing is that
I would just like --
I would really use the crew
in kind of like a mean way.
I mean, I love the crew so much,
this group of incredible people
up in Vancouver Island.
But you know, late at night
after 12 hours of work
and you want to go home
and Rylea just has one line
to say that's like --
Okay, one time,
it was at the end of,
I don't remember the episode,
seven or something like that,
and the line is like,
"Best day ever, Mommy."
And she wouldn't say it.
I guess she didn't have
a good day, and she was like,
"That's not authentic."
[ Laughter ]
But we were all just,
like, really trying
to get her to say
"best day ever."
And so we would enlist
various crew members
to do just ridiculous things.
I remember calling Jess over,
who's a sound guy,
to dance for her,
and just anybody to do
absolutely anything.
Special man C-- Um...
I just called him "special man
Cam", but that was his nickname,
was the second AD's nickname.
I mean, really, it was --
kids are [bleep]
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
Yeah, no.
-Like, don't work with them.
-Why I asked that question,
'cause I have a kid
who's almost 4.
-Yeah.
-And the idea that I could get
him to say something...
-Right.
I mean, the amount of power
that they have on a set
is outrageous.
-Yeah. Or, by the way,
everywhere else.
-Right. That's true.
That's true.
-[ Laughing ] Yeah.
-In the beginning,
she was such a sweetheart,
and then by the end of --
it was nine months up there,
she realized that, like,
everyone had to do
what she wanted.
-Yeah.
-You know? I mean, I love her.
Bless her.
Bless her, bless her, bless her.
-No, no, that's coming across,
how much you love her.
Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
I mean, she's a power-mad
tyrant, but she's --
oh, my God, she's my heart.
[ Laughter ]
We have something in common.
We adore Adam Sandler.
-Oh, yeah, I do.
-And I thought,
as Adam Sandler fans went,
I was right at the top
of the list, but you...
-And then you met me.
-I met you.
Well, I didn't meet you as much
as I heard that you're --
basically, like, this is what
you get for Christmas presents.
-Yes. Yeah.
-So this is, by the way,
not a signed photograph
from Adam Sandler.
-No, it's not.
-You got his co-star.
-Mr. Larson.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
So, people in your life knew
that this would be
an appropriate Christmas gift.
-Yeah, my boyfriend's sister,
Rachel, gave that to me,
and I'm getting it framed
right now.
It's very exciting.
And yeah, it was.
It was a really great gift,
but it didn't stop there.
-Okay, yeah, no, this was...
this is a T-shirt.
-My boyfriend gave me that.
-Okay, that's beautiful.
-Yeah, yeah.
-So, you did really well
for yourself.
-I did really well.
-That's quite a haul.
-It was a really exciting
Christmas, 'cause I got those,
and then I also gave some
"Happy Gilmore" paraphernalia,
as well.
I gave some Subway shirts out,
you know?
-Yeah.
-If you're a hard fan, you'll
know what I'm talking about.
I think I might name
my first child --
hopefully, they're not
an [bleep] --
-- "Sonny."
-Sonny?
-I don't know. Yeah.
-It would at least make it funny
if they were an [bleep]
-Right, but I was bringing it
back to the Rylea thing.
-Yes, of course. Of course.
No, no, I knew.
I know you're not just like,
out of nowhere,
just saying, "Kids are [bleep]"
-Yeah, yeah.
-You've established.
You've laid down proof.
Hey, you put this on Instagram,
and this is not your pet,
this photo, right?
-No, that's not my pet.
-Okay, but it looks like
you allowed it to get
a lot closer
than I would allow
this animal to get.
So, where is this and why did
you let this happen?
-I mean, I was at the park.
-Okay, you're at a park
in New York City.
-I was at the park
-Yeah, no, but the question is,
why didn't you move your foot?
-I mean, to be honest,
I thought about...
Oh, why didn't I move my foot?
Well, I want to be close to it.
Of course!
-You did want to be close to it.
-Of course.
-Okay, so I think that's
the story here, Margaret.
-I know, but I feel bad, because
the end of this story --
well, I've never really
told anyone this,
but the end of this story
is that the poor little guy,
like, wanted to be my friend,
but I didn't really --
like, I could have picked it up
or something,
but I thought maybe it could
have rabies.
-It 100% has rabies.
[ Laughter ]
What are you talking about?
You know, I mean, I think
that's the first thing,
like, when you land
at LaGuardia,
they're like, "Don't take
the squirrels home."
-Yeah, no, but it kind of
followed me.
Like, I left and it was
following me,
and I just felt bad because
I was like, maybe the squirrel
needs something from me,
maybe it's ask--
But I didn't pick it up
because of the rabies thing.
-On behalf of all of us,
thank you for making
the right decision
when the moment of truth came.
But we do have a very special
surprise for you.
The squirrel's here.
No, I'm kidding.
-Oh.
God, I really thought
Adam Sandler was gonna walk out.
Terrible day.
-Yeah, exactly.
-Sorry about that.
Yeah, we really blew it.
But can you please,
just before we go,
can you say, "Best day ever"?
-[Childlike voice]
Best day ever, Mommy.
-See, there you go.
Margaret Qualley, everybody!
"Maid" is streaming now
on Netflix.